every single race obviously has a very
favorable view of people in their own
race with one exception and it was white
liberals have a very negative the graph
is like it's like black people Asians
Mexicans and then the negative which for
white people uh for hating white people
there's no other ethnic group or
combination of factors where somebody
hates themselves as much as like white
liberals do
here's the first thing we're getting
into okay yep all right so I've started
taking a little bit more um interest in
my parents okay okay
um why do you go okay so I noticed that
I feel like men look really good when
you're kind of like sitting in a chair
sports your back you know you're up like
this right real proper posture why do
you guys have these like deep-seated
chairs where you like especially for
shorter guys like me look at me look at
me in this doesn't me sitting in the
back this is intentional okay what are
you like six two I'm five eight it makes
me look like a
like the stay puffed Marshmallow guy
from Ghostbusters I think you do this
intentionally just to get one over on
your guests like you've already got me
mentally no podcast not at all I'm not
trying to do that oh this is not it's
not discriminating against anybody below
five eight okay all right did you see
the uh Elon BBC interview thing where
they did the usual put him on a stool
make him feel as uncomfortable as
possible the stool still had the price
tag on it nice I did not say that I
didn't know is that like part of their
just presumably BBC's taxpayer funded so
they're like we're not going to allow
any money to be wasted we'll take this
stool back once the richest man in the
world damn not good I didn't see it I
saw like a two or three minute clip of
that and he wrecked him who wrecked who
Elon wrecked that BBC guy oh yeah I
don't like Elon very much so we might
but you've got to concede every so often
that he does win
um yeah no he definitely has a lot of
wins I'm very big on like when you
confront people with things I say this
all the time bring examples it's
something I talk about a lot when I
whenever we're talking about an idea or
an ideology or Theory or an ex or
whatever I'm always like such as and
then I'll give like one or two or three
examples because it's really important
to ground out what you say otherwise you
can just people give like the most
Superfluous advice that sometimes like
what the [__] are you talking about
right and it's like give like an example
like two so you can understand and when
the guy did it to Elon he was like oh
yeah like racism has increased all over
the platform and I was like well how and
it's like at the very least I think
there was a one organization that did
like a study saying they measured like
so he could have at least brought that
up but he's like well in my feed and
he's like really where and he's like
well I haven't used my feed in six weeks
and he's like well how did you know and
he's like well uh uh I was like you
don't even have one example what are you
doing dude yeah I've noticed that you
ask people for definitions a lot so what
do you mean by that yeah what do you
mean when you say that term
and that's kind of the same so yeah so
we're like on the same because I want to
have like a real conversation I'm not
here to just [__] preach at the
[__] camera I'm in front of my stream
for eight hours a day I could do that
like if I'm talking to somebody let's
have like an actual conversation so it
drives me crazy yeah how did it feel to
have Milo yiannopoulos make Richard
Spencer seem reasonable
um you know props to Richard Spencer for
either hiding his horrible ideology or
doing genuine Reformation I'm not sure
what she's doing you know I take people
I meet people where they're at
um Milo is I I feel like I understand
Milo pretty well maybe what is he who is
he no
um man my chat made fun of me when I
says but I feel like Milo I want to say
Milo for a brief moment in time was like
one of the top three to five most
popular political punny people in the
world in like 2016 right or in that era
he was going to colleges he had books
out he was everybody knew him all over
the world he was making everybody mad he
was on this like alt-right slash Trump
binge and then man that pedo convo
really just did a number on him
he just yeah the beginning of the Spiral
down did you see the Vlog where he
flew to Hawaii to try and throw his
engagement ring into an active volcano
and then the Hawaii local environmental
organization said we don't let people go
and throw personal possessions into
active volcanoes so he got a bottle of
vodka got on a rented a boat and then
was drinking the bottle of vodka showing
how expensive the ring was on his phone
before he blink just throw it into the
Pacific I did not see that that was a
sad sad Vlog yeah to watch cheers so
where is he now who is he now
um I think he's just desperately trying
to carve out some political Niche
um and and right now it seems like
that's like this Christian nationalist
thing but he like exists solely in these
strange spaces on telegram
um he has no like social media anywhere
because he's banned from everything and
he doesn't really have like a coherent
political ideology or lifestyle or
platform or anything so he's just like
yeah he's like grifted into this very
very Niche weird world where he's trying
to like make some kind of name for
himself but it doesn't seem like it's
going too well it seems to me watching
him against you and then also I've seen
him do a couple of other little
interviews over the last couple of years
it's kind of like watching a punch drunk
boxer trying to get back into the ring
one last time all of the
he did have kind of charm it was a real
trolley charm but there was something
like Whimsical and and kind of funny and
sort of subversive about what he used to
do
and then it was so just like icky and
gloves off but not in a ruthless way
kind of in a like a scrappy scrabbling
bottom of the barrel way with that
debate with you and then you bring up
like one point there's one bit of
pushback that you get like one
legitimate piece of pushback which was
still couched quite a lot for the people
that haven't seen it you brought up the
thing that he was canceled for as he
started accusing you of like having kids
that were going to be future pedophiles
yeah like this is not the stance for you
of all people to take and then that
immediately just broke his brain and I
thought dude like if you're gonna
[__] dish it out for 50 minutes at
least be able to take it on the other
side and he couldn't so it really just I
don't know it's like the the death
throws of some [__] like old singer
who's touring again and doesn't can't
hit the high notes yeah that's basically
how I view it yeah
what has changed then with the landscape
that means that Milo is no longer like
is it just that that kind of trolley
alt-right stuff is not called anymore
yeah so something um I give myself a lot
of credit for is I've been doing online
content now in a fairly relevant way for
about 13 years and in order to maintain
at a level to where you're still
accruing new followers where people
still want to look at you for what's
going on a modern day you kind of have
to adapt to the changing kind of like
political Landscapes
um I'm sure stuff changed fast in the
past too but man today on the internet
political movements will come and go in
like one to four years depending on the
movement Milo definitely thrived in this
kind of like alt-right explosive era
where trolling and attacking college
kids and being as provocative as
possible and pushing back against the
sjws you know that's what we used to
call woke people back in the 2016 days
that was like the height of what he did
but I feel like he never really adapted
past that and he's still kind of like
looking back towards that you know like
you said like he's got like his
provocative attitude and all of that and
he's got his you know I think men are
speaking copied from like Hitchens uh
where he's like you know this oration
style but he doesn't really have any
substance anymore like no offense but
like are we really looking to like Milo
yiannopoulos for the ideal Christian
type of lifestyle and now he's like
super pro censorship and it's like yeah
I don't know she's very strange you know
I did a debate in Qatar about
masculinity about six weeks ago and they
put up a montage of a bunch of different
people commenting on how feminism had
gone too far the [__] first person
was Milo yiannopoulos I had to kind of
couch it and I was like look I do and
then after that was Rogan and then there
was Peterson and blah blah blah
guys if if you have brought me here to
try and defend Milo yiannopoulos I'm
like that's not the job that I was sent
here to do like there's criticisms that
we can have about all sorts of stuff
like don't I'm not gonna jump on that
bandwagon uh another thing that's
interesting is how are you talking about
how quick political movements come and
go like Milo and Nick Fuentes I mean
that was the shortest relationship in
history
yeah I'm gonna be honest I called all of
that I told these [__] that
when the EA stuff popped up that this is
going to be like a two to three month
thing and it felt like Fuentes banked a
lot on yay being like his new explosive
reach to the public and I think Milo
also was like looking at like his way
back into Fame but yeah he's done this
before right where he wanted to run for
president I think in 2016 and he came
and went in like two weeks and then he
repeated like the same thing again I was
like how are you taking this guy
seriously the I love Hitler guy who has
no foundation for any political belief
whatsoever
um yeah that it was a short relationship
it was dumb I don't know how much you
follow on telegram no not much these
guys are fighting like crazy like I
think Fuentes just dropped yesterday
that this guy called Ali Alexander who
was the leader of the stop the steel
movement
is like a pedophile or something and
that Milo yiannopoulos was defending him
and I think Milo yiannopoulos a few days
ago is trying to drop things proving
that people are like they're all it's so
much crazy yeah but that's always like
the go-to I think with everybody yeah do
you do you know the word nuns do you
know what that is doesn't mean like
stupid in British or something Nancy is
pedo oh I didn't know that okay yeah so
you'll see if it's ever anybody in
England that's accusing someone else of
being a pedo it would be that wasn't
there something didn't Nick Fuentes say
that Milo is taking Percocet to stop
himself from being gay isn't he
medicating himself out of his
homosexuality that's what he says so my
when I'm writing stuff on this on people
I like sources I need screenshots I need
videos these guys are making a lot of
clumsy show that was any proof of
anything so it's really funny like I'll
probably repeat some of it if I'm trying
to like trigger some of them but is it
actually true I I have no idea I mean
Fuentes
I watched Fuentes too I think it was
either yesterday the day before and he's
like I heard from people who were
working with Milo and they have no
reason to lie tell me about this and
that and that and it's like couldn't be
more yeah I don't like come on dude yeah
give me at least like a screenshot or
something yeah talk to me about
um being on stage when someone like Milo
really tries to sort of take the gloves
off it seems like you can keep your cool
which I think is a pretty impressive
thing to be able to do is that innate is
that something that you've developed do
you ever get asked for tips on debating
and what would you tell people
um I've I've always been like a really
cool person I don't know why
um the the my transition I worked a job
when I was uh 17 18 I worked at
McDonald's okay lovely fast food
restaurant and I was so good at handling
irate customers that somebody in line
there noticed and then recommended maybe
for another job at a casino that I
worked at where I also worked at
graveyard shift because I could handle a
lot of Ira customers so I've always been
good at just like dealing with people
that are just like this is dumb like
whatever
um so I I don't know why I've had that
skill baked into me for a long time now
when I run into people like that I have
to be very strategic I like I have to
think a lot about how I'm supposed to
deal with it because my background in
Internet [__] talking is huge and that's
very very fun for me like if somebody
wants to roll around in the dirt I will
gladly like let's have like a two-hour
screaming match I would love nothing
more but it doesn't really look good on
me so I have to be like very measured
there are a lot of things I wanted to
say to Milo and I have to like pick my
spots very carefully
um why didn't you do that
uh two reasons so one in the 2016 era of
Politics the way that you communicated
strength to people was through like
destroying people like screaming at them
you know going hard like oh you're so
[__] stupid blah blah like that's how
we did it and that's whatever you know
that's why that was where my comeuppance
was was like being that really like loud
unruly angry kind of left-leaning person
that would destroy people
um but then 2020 onwards now the way you
communicate strength is this like quiet
stoic type of like manly like nothing
affects me so now when I'm like dealing
with people the way that you deliver the
insult has to be like it's got to be
like a bit more cool a bit more
collected a bit less emotionally
impacted so I kind of have to think when
I'm navigating conversations like I I
have to attack him because he's
obviously saying some wild [__] and it
would be really funny and have good
attacks but I can't attack him in a way
that makes it seem like I'm upset so
there's like a whole like strategy to
like dealing with people that are like
really trying to needle you you know why
do you think the uh landscape of what is
being cool or being assertive or being
powerful has changed is this just a
trend that for a while it was called to
be the outgoing gregarious one and
therefore there's like a flip-flop which
is the opposite of that or is there
something else going on because I know
exactly the thing that you mean it's
almost this kind of like sardonic aloof
standoffish kind of like cynical kind of
thing that's going on what's happening
there
um I mean I don't know I just I follow
the internet Trends I don't know where
they come from
um pretty pervasive though you know you
look at Twitter no one's ever like
calling somebody out directly it's
always sub tweeting little Snipes and
jibes and sarcastic comments
yeah I truly have no idea I'm not sure I
don't even know if it's real sometimes
it's very strange like um you exist in
kind of these nanosphere spaces like
something I hear a lot of people say
things is like oh like to be really
emotional is feminine and to be a man is
to be stoic and the only way that
statement works is if anger isn't
included as an emotion because men get
very angry sometimes so I'll see some
people talk about the importance of
stoicism and stuff but man when they're
going off on women they're very
emotional but they're angry emotional so
but that doesn't count so
um I don't know the whole world is kind
of silly but I try to I have to keep in
mind like how do people view me how do I
represent myself so it's something I
just have to try to keep in mind but you
know I don't know where exactly it comes
from or why people are where they're at
and you know like current media trends
online yeah speaking about the Milo and
Nick explosion or implosion it seems
like pretty much every other political
organization like The Young Turks versus
the entire left uh Crowder versus
Shapiro the scientist versus Trump like
everything just seems to be kind of
falling in on itself the trans movement
versus other parts of the trans movement
as well what's that in have you got any
idea about what indicative of that or
why it's happening
um
there's two thoughts I have
one is the thought that Spencer brought
up in my conversation that people need
like an enemy I kind of wonder if
without a strong rallying figure
everybody just kind of like turns on
themselves so personally I think Biden
is doing a really good job as president
uh for a writing reasons but Biden is
not like a character that most people
want to like either die attacking or die
defending he just doesn't Inspire like
that kind of like yeah Biden you know
um so people on the right you can't
really hate him as much as like you
could like Hillary Clinton and people on
the left don't really want to defend him
as much as they would like Obama or
Bernie Sanders right so maybe without
like that strong Center like lightning
rod
um that inspires like defense and
aggression now people are kind of like
looking at everybody else for who they
want to fight with like everybody on the
right everybody on the right is fighting
amongst themselves oh my God the Shapiro
Crowder thing was insane when that blew
up the um the Trump DeSantis stuff is
like Brewing on the horizon with
occasional spillovers that whole
Christian International stuff with
Fuentes Alex Elliott yeah it's okay and
then on the left thankfully they're a
smaller faction of our party but the the
progressives and like fighting with
everybody is like a huge thing that's
blowing up online too so
um yeah what's the second one um the
second one is uh there's something I've
been talking about a lot more
um I think our identity is getting more
fractured in really negative ways it's
hard to I try to keep in mind like I
don't know what's unique Now versus this
is always existed but I'm like a 34 year
old guy and this is my whole life so
many people you know so maybe I just
maybe over exaggerate the present
recentism or whatever but it really
feels like we can't be proud of any part
of our identity right now
um for a variety of reasons two big
reasons so on the left it feels like
we're we identify ourselves by like how
much we're supposed to hate ourselves
you know like okay I'm white and that's
horrible because my ancestors said
slaves and I'm part of a white
supremacist system and colonialism means
I'm exploiting the world and capitalism
means a lot like it's like all of it is
such a [__] drag and then for people
on the right
um especially as they've taken this more
populist Ben people on the right can't
even be proud of America anymore because
now they all hate [__] corporations
and they hate like everything related to
like
um like everything that America does now
so like here's like two examples that
I'll give I don't know how controversial
will be with you or your audience but
like in my opinion okay I think that the
vaccine is like I think that that was
the perfect shining example of like
American capitalism you had the
government under Trump do warp speed
trying to incentivize Private Industry
that is like globalized it's working
with different companies all over the
world Pfizer biotech to use publicly
funded research in the United States to
create a vaccine for a novel virus in
less than 12 months that's like uh that
is like a shining example of like only
the United States of America could have
done that but it's such a politically
captive topic that nobody can feel good
about it people on the left are like uh
yeah I guess you know and people on the
right are like no [__] that even though
Trump is like please like the vaccine so
like we can't feel good about that I
think that Ukraine regardless if you
feel Pro or negative Ukraine the support
that we gave them the way that we out of
the Intel the way that we LED NATO and
Europe or whatever through that I think
it's also been an exemplary attitude a
stark contrast to the horrible [__]
we've done in Iraq and Afghanistan like
this is good American leadership on a
country that deserves to be defended we
did a really good way but it's such a
politically captive idea that nobody can
feel good about it so we have this
identity in the United States we all
hate each other nobody can feel good
about anything the United States does
the right hates every we don't have like
neocons anymore who are at the very
least like oh well hey we love our big
businesses because everybody hates big
business now everybody loves hates
everything about themselves and it's
like [__] like where's your identity at
so everyone just like fights with each
other hates each other and it's like
well [__] you know people coming
together and rallying together over
shared hatreds is always going to be
stronger than people coming together
over shared loves like almost there was
a study that I saw and and it starts in
2012.
if you ask Democrats whether they love
Democrats or they like their own party
more than they hate the other in 2012 it
flips and people are basically protest
voting everything it's I'm voting for
not the thing that I don't like as
opposed to voting for the thing that I
do like true and this with Purity
spirals which is what you said at the
beginning which is if you are bound
together of the mutual hatred of an
outgroup you have to continually shave
off members on the outside of your own
inner group to continue to be more and
more pure and keep on pointing them out
as pariahs and scapegoats and so that's
the person that we're not I'm not that
I'm not this I'm not the other like
um white gay privilege like if you're
gay but you're also white kind of not
that gay anymore bro gay people are like
the straight people of like the LGBT
like I'll see people like white gay
people you mean the guys that have all
appropriated black female language and
I'm like holy [__] dude white gay guys
are gonna be feeling really weird what
was it like was it like what 30 or 40
years ago they were all dying of AIDS
and now they're like next on the
chopping block and they're like holy
[__] you know yep Jesus yeah yeah if
you're white and you're gay you're just
not that gay anymore yeah like you're an
honorary straight essentially and
especially if you're conservative if
you're conservative white and Douglas
Murray Douglas Murray is like one of the
straightest men in the world now for
that precise reason so yeah I think it's
an interesting point to say that Biden
is so milk toast to most people that he
hasn't been able to inspire either
support or hatred which has caused both
of those things to just get turned
inward I think that's I think that's an
interesting which is kind of sad because
Biden's goal coming into office was to
be like a great unifier which I think to
some extent he has accomplished and that
he's not like relentlessly [__] on
the right as much as people say he's
like he tries to be pretty careful he's
just like oh I don't like the mega
people that are trying to protest the
election but for the most part bin is
not like relentlessly attacking
conservatives and Republicans not
anywhere as much as it could be but I
think as a result of that like
Republicans don't really care much about
him I don't think that they're like
obsessed over but being unobjectionable
and like uniting in that regard has
actually ended up turning everybody in
on themselves which has fractured
everything even more yeah in a way kind
of yeah because like how many
conservative it feels like now I feel
like if you were to pull an average
conservative now it feels like their
most hated figure would be like either
like Trump or to Santa's as they're like
fighting against each other that you
have like these conservative moments and
then like all the other conservative
people the Laura loomers the Margie
Taylor greens that are like this huge
like faction forming fighting in the
conservative party right now like
they're just like buying this you know
whatever Democrat socialist who cares
and then it's like all like the
conservative stuff you know and trans
people and they really want to talk
about you oh my God uh did you see the
article saying that Liberals are more
unhappy than conservatives it was a
bunch of different studies that came out
um it was in Atlanta where the whole
thing on stream two or three days ago
yeah yeah what are your thoughts off the
back of that well the part of what I
just told you I ripped straight from
that article the idea that liberals
Define themselves by like um like all
the things that they hate so like if I'm
like a white person I kind of have to
feel bad about it because like any
wealth I have is like a privilege that
came from the exploitation of people
from colonialist mindsets and whites
blah blah they're like yeah that's that
type of mindset
is probably really really really
negative and I think that I think that
the left it's I have this thing on
stream that I say where if I'm talking
to an audience I'm always going to talk
from a pretty far left perspective we're
going to talk about systems we're going
to talk about class we're going to talk
about like what are the things that the
government can do to create like a good
environment for you right because that's
what I'm concerned about like on a broad
level but if I'm giving advice to like
an individual I'm going to be the most
hyper like anarcho libertarian ever like
if I'm talking to somebody like oh can I
get some advice like yeah here's some
advice you care more about you than
anybody else ever will you're the only
one that can improve your situation
nobody's going to give you a handout
nobody gives a [__] about you you're
going to do whatever you can like on
your own to get ahead in life and that's
it right and I I talk about this
sometimes and people people sometimes
try to call me like hypocritical or like
when I give advice to individual like
what do you mean what aren't you going
to recognize that it's not fair for this
guy blah blah blah blah it's like yeah
sure but to an individual who the [__]
cares right like you can sit there and
blame systems all you want and be a
loser or you can do your best overcoming
like that's all you could do you know
how do you marry those two World Views
then how do you blend those two
um
it's like it's very it's very difficult
but like on a on a personal level I
understand that I exist as part of a
system and there are some things that
are unfair but like all you can do is
try your best right
but it's very very difficult as a
left-leaning person if you play video
games yeah have you ever played League
of Legends no okay this must be true of
like sports I would imagine I never
played like football or basketball but I
imagine that in sports there's probably
a difficulty sometimes where it's easy
to blame teammates for your losses right
um I played a single player game called
Starcraft growing up and I loved that
game it's one on one if you lost it was
your [__] fault full stop when you
play Team games it's very difficult to
figure out what's what's your fault or
why did you lose was it my teammates did
they [__] up and you can get into a
mindset you start blaming everybody else
and what happens is you take no personal
accountability and the real mindset for
improving in those games and everybody
knows this even if they're upset at the
time you're not gonna say they'll tell
you the real mindset for improving is
all you can do is take the most
responsibility for your own actions as
much as you can and try to improve on
that sometimes you might be in
unwinnable games where your teammates
will cause you to lose but who cares
find out what you can improve on and go
forward and we know that's true for
games we probably know it's true for
sports but then as soon as we come into
the real world it's like oh you're black
you didn't get a job they were probably
racist oh you're a woman uh you know
your application I turn over they were
probably sexist how can you expect that
that mindset doesn't [__] destroy a
person's ability to navigate the world
when they've constantly been told that
classes around them are what are keeping
them down and the amount of yeah I just
I feel like the amount of personal
agency you have goes rips the agentic
person out out of it there was a really
interesting part where it said that
um one of the reasons or one of the
potential justifications for why it
would be the case that Liberals are more
depressed is because they correctly
perceive injustices in the world that
was Matthew iglesias's like take on it
oh that was it could be potentially yeah
that basically they're more in tune with
what's going on that's bad but I I don't
know that that liberal boys are
experiencing more depression than
conservative girls because of that like
because they can the liberal boys are
more in tune than a female who's got all
manner of hormones going on and her body
image is up in the air and she's 14
years old and she's now a sexual object
and God knows what I'm supposed to do
with myself and everyone's treating me
in a different way and I'm becoming a
woman and I'm having periods and all
this stuff and being tapped into
injustices is more than I mean it I I
could see it being the case um for me a
lot of stuff related to women has when
you get turned on to a lot of the really
weird [__] that goes along with being a
woman especially in like this world as
soon as I notice that that's a really
sad and depressing thing to to take into
account and this is [__] yeah and as
a guy like I like Overlook all of that
and there's so many I have to be careful
now even like there will be people that
a woman will ask me oh like I'm gonna
show with this guy like do you think
he's cool and I just feel like yeah this
tastes like super cool it's whatever and
now I know I can never say that about a
guy unless I've seen him interact with a
woman because how he interacts with me
doesn't [__] matter because there are
guys having react with super cool very
polite like just like this is an
exemplary dude he's a really awesome guy
and then like I'll see him in another
and in at least one circumcision he
tries a real woman that I was like
friends but I'm like what the [__] is
wrong with you dude
um and it's like an insane [__] world
where it's like yeah when I get tuned
under some of that stuff I could
definitely see it being more like [__]
um when I was a carpet cleaner that was
the point in my life where I was the
most Libertarian where I was like I need
to do what I can I gotta work hard I
gotta figure this out blah blah blah
blah and holy [__] it wasn't until I got
rich that I realized wow there is so
much of life that is [__] [__] uh
well like in terms of like how much
easier life is in in every single regard
when you become wealthy
um I don't know if it's because I was a
commuter a lot but a lot of the misery
in my life uh surrounded usually was
around my [__] car okay I drove a
piece of [__] car
um things like flat tires or speeding
tickets that's like a kick in the ass
for like three to six months depending
on how [__] you get right if you crack
a wheel anybody from Nebraska that
drives on I-80 going back and for forth
from Omaha to Council Bluffs knows it
when it snows those potholes are [__]
insane that [__] will [__] you over and
then like every single bad thing gets
worse because of every other thing right
so like let's say that I crack a wheel
okay well now I gotta call a friend to
get the [__] out of here I have to leave
my car somewhere on the side of the road
I gotta write a big sign that says
please don't [__] tell me they're
gonna tell you anyway now that he gets
towed I got a 75 fee at least from the
state and now every single day it sits
in this tow yard it's like an extra
hundred dollars and it's just like so
much [__] stress and then it's a rich
person I was like I get pulled over for
whatever the [__] I hire traffic lawyer
make it go away I don't give a [__]
about anything right I could go total my
car and Uber somewhere else to go to a
dealership and buy it I don't like it
the life is so much different for like a
wealthy person in so many ways or for
like my kid for example
um I'm trying to think of like what I
wanted to go to school it's like I want
to go to a good I wanted to be in the
best school district so I just buy a
house the best school district and then
we move there right and then over the
pandemic when people have to stay home
right or even before the pandemic [__]
my kid is in like first grade and these
[__] are getting assigned
laptops and they get like take home like
holy [__] and there are other places
North Omaha South where these kids like
barely have like functioning textbooks
and I don't know from the eyes like I
said when I was a poor person like okay
I'm gonna work hard libertarian I can do
this blah blah blah but then it's a
wealthy person I'm like I was like damn
this is some [__] [__] my life and my
kids like are so much easier now just
because I have money versus like what it
would be otherwise and [__] that kind of
sucks here so to send it back
um I'm not saying you should be
depressed because you see the Injustice
of the world more or whatever but I do
think that there is something to be said
where like when you start to notice more
[__] you're like oof that is kind of
like shitty that does kind of suck yeah
for the people that haven't read that
article some of the really interesting
stuff that I found uh there's a 10
percentage points gap between the share
of conservative versus liberals who
report being very happy in virtually
every iteration of the GSS study since
1972 conservatives do not just report
high levels of happiness they also
report high levels of meaning in their
lives the positive association between
conservative ideology and happiness only
rarely reversed liberals were happier
than conservatives and only 5 out of 92
countries and never in the United States
Studies have repeatedly found the
conservative of both politicians and
Layman's tend to be more conventionally
attractive than liberals and have better
sex lives people who are healthier in
childhood have shown to be more likely
to become conservatives as adults
meanwhile people with higher measured
cognitive ability also likely to support
economic conservatism and cultural
liberalism
what the [__] like why what's going on
there
um I mean we'd have to talk through each
of those things I understand yeah from
from the I mean we can if you want to I
I think I feel like here's what I feel
okay I have a lot of um uh protective
factors that make me able to deal with
adversity very well and I feel like
left-leaning people don't equip you with
those tools at all
um you have to be able to be confronted
with a difficult situation and overcome
it and it feels like from the left our
idea of compassion for children is
removing as much adversity from possible
but you need a little bit at least to
like be able to function in the world
you know and as you remove the ability
for people to deal with any type of
adversity and then you give them excuse
after excuse after excuse for why
everything is unfair everything is
unjust everything is horrible then it's
like what do you think is going to
happen something that's a little bit
telling um I don't know what you read of
that article but did you see the thing
where it was like a person's view of
their race and ethnicity versus other
people no so in that article
um every single race obviously has a
very favorable view of people in the
their own race with one exception and it
was white liberals have a very negative
the graph is like it's like black people
Asians Mexicans and then the negative
which for white people uh for hating
white people like come on really that's
so [__] crazy you're like
flagellating yourself yeah it's insane
and it's like holy [__] yeah wow okay
that's a really interesting uh graph if
you it's just like seeing like the big
bar the big bar and then the other big
boy like Jesus there's no other ethnic
group or combination of factors where
somebody hates themselves as much as
like white liberals do I wonder did you
have a look does it show that longitude
in any does it show when that kicked in
because I can't imagine it would have
been the same I don't think it doesn't
show at longitudinally but that article
frames everything in the perspective
from 2011 and onwards it calls it the
great awokening yeah yes yeah I remember
I remember seeing that bit in other news
this episode is brought to you by seed
seeds DSO one daily symbiotic is one of
the most advanced probiotics and
prebiotics on the market with 24 strains
it is a bra broad spectrum probiotic and
Prebiotic formulated for Digestive gut
immune and additional system benefits
with 53.6 billion AFU it's two in one
capsule technology protects against
stomach acid and digestive enzymes for
viability through your digestion this
means that the probiotics will actually
make it to the end of the small
intestine for delivery which massively
increases its Effectiveness for you all
of this means that your digestion will
move more smoothly so if you've been
considering using some probiotics and
prebiotics for a while and you want to
make an upgrade to your digestion seed
is the most advanced option on the
market you can get 15 off your first
month by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
seed.com Modern wisdom and using the
code modern wisdom a checkout that's
seed.com modern wisdom and modern wisdom
a checkout one of the other things that
I know you've spoken about a good bit
recently is kind of the concerns of too
much Freedom so if you just blast open
all of the doors you don't need to
adhere to any expected Traditions there
are no stereotypes no archetypes nothing
is grounded in biological fact and then
you know perpetuated by culture which
causes everybody to have to find
themselves out from first principles
it's like you're a man okay there are no
expectations for what you're supposed to
be as a man which means that your job
Sono is to deal with the existential
pain the crushing weight of existence
and just work out what you're supposed
to be going forward I wonder whether
unlimited degrees of freedom causes
people to just become nihilistic it's
like existentially [__] crushed and
then they go oh I I don't really know
how to do this and they give up as
opposed to perhaps if you do have some
slightly more conflicted but slightly
more constrained expectations for a
conservative maybe that does give you
guard rails which actually gives you a
little bit more movement in the right
direction yeah I think our identity
truly it's fractured among every person
that we've made is fractured and in
society to some extent like when we
think of what does it mean to be
successful at XYZ we tell ourselves a
story that it means I want to be the
best person that I can be but that's
truly I think that's a lie I think what
you want to be is you want to be the
best person that like everybody thinks
you can be or everybody says you can be
like what does it mean to be the best
version of a man it's not just what you
think it means to be a man it's but what
does everybody think it means to be a
man and then and then achieving success
on that level where everybody else is
looking towards it I think is truly
where a lot of the good films are going
because we have we're social beings
right we're we socialize we that's how
humans succeed we didn't we never lived
as like individual Hunters you know
we're very much like pack animals social
creatures so if every single person
in a society has their own view of
everything
some people will be okay probably a very
very small minority less than like two
percent probably are like lit like that
type of role I like that type of well
it's fun for me I'm a very discreet
autistic like ah whatever but for most
people
um you want to be the best of what
everybody agrees is the best to be it's
kind of it's like it's the age-old I
remember the 90s and the 2000s there
were lots of jokes like this like you're
unique just like everyone else you know
when you want to have like the most
unique and cool fashion you don't really
want the most shooting in cool fashion
you want the thing that everybody else
wants but just not everybody else can
afford to get but it has to be something
that we all agree is the coolest thing
and then that's what makes you like the
most unique you know but but it's it's
just kind of it's this weird like
delusion we have where we're like oh
yeah like I really do want to be like a
truly unique and outstanding individual
it's like not really that's terrifying
you just want to fit very neatly within
the fold of what's socially acceptable
but you want to do it like in the in the
very narrow parts and not everybody can
afford you know is modern liberalism
incompatible with happiness on average
do you think in the way that a lot of
people in the sort of super Progressive
uh position hold it
when you're okay in order to truly learn
about like Electronics when you take
things apart like remotes and [__] you
don't learn anything until you actually
[__] put it back together okay and I
think one of the problems we have
especially on the left is we deconstruct
so many different ideas but we don't ask
ourselves why the [__] were they there
the way that they were you know I think
they're interested in electronics what
justison's Electronics like Justin's
funds oh I have no idea what that is but
I'll say you've not heard of
chesterton's funds no what is that you
there's no way that you've gone through
your life and not heard of this So
Justin's fence is there is a fence in a
field somebody walks up to it a
conservative or and a liberal both walk
up to it and it's kind of just a panel
of fence in the middle of a field and
they think well there's there's no point
for this to be here the conservative
presumes someone has put this here even
though I can't work out why it's here
we'd better leave it the liberal says
there's evidently no use for it let's
tear it down it's basically don't throw
the baby out with the bathwater or don't
throw bath water out until you've worked
out why there might be a baby in there
okay sure that's exactly what I'm
talking about basically yes
um yeah but so I think we had an issue
with that so when you ask like is
liberalism
um you asked is liberalism incompatible
with like the current iteration the most
modern 2023 version of what most people
like caricature as liberalism is it
incompatible with happiness on average I
I think I think it can be but I think
we're pushing a little bit too far we're
not asking ourselves like you know are
we throwing out the baby with the
bathwater basically
um there's a lot of cool things that can
happen with deconstructing gender roles
and I think there's a lot of value to
throwing out some things like I think
that um for instance women can be more
successful than we ever thought possible
that seems to be a a thing that we're
even more surprised about every single
day especially when it comes to school
correct but
does that mean that we need to have no
gender roles whatsoever like do we need
to abolish every single thing related to
like male and female archetypes because
there's a lot of people that draw a lot
of value from those probably not we
probably don't have to do that but
people are so Keen to get rid of
everything that it's hard to ground
like any of our conversations anymore in
in any type of real thing you know yes
um well if you demonize motherhood that
means that there are innate biological
urges for women to become mothers but
this self-hatred thing that you
mentioned about white liberals must also
happen for women who maybe feel like
they're supposed to have a career but I
I kind of like the idea of being a mum I
think 86 of women say that being a
stay-at-home mom is an option that they
aspire to have like just the potential
that they could have but you know the
self-hatred would be rampant if you were
to actually be truthful about that which
causes internal conflict and strife yeah
I would imagine so that 86 number sounds
really high but I mean yeah I mean I
imagine an option that I would aspire to
have like the bar is set very low sure
um yeah I mean yeah I think I agree so
it's just it's so [__] hard for
people to um it's really hard for people
to like live with and accept that other
people around them can be different like
it feels like people are very keen to
just like Hammer home like every [__]
idea like uh Francis like on the left
for progressives we talk a lot about
like diversity of thought everything or
diversity or whatever and it's not very
much diversity in a lot of friend groups
on the left or the right you know like
people say oh I've got like a
conservative friend it's like no you
don't you've got a friend who's like a
conservative but they hate Trump they're
not a big fan of guns they just like
don't want a 25 an hour minimum wage
right show me a conservative friend you
have that like drinks moonshine and
wears a mega hat okay show me like a
real because right there's not like
we're very much like separated from each
other whatever the case though was that
the case in the 90s
um where we had friends that were very
different from each other
I I feel like the internet has changed
things a lot because now you can hyper
select groups of friends and individuals
you never could before like you couldn't
really find if you had really extremist
ideas to some extent you were forced to
confront the people around you and kind
of uh integrate you couldn't tumble down
into your own Echo chamber on Reddit or
telegram or Discord because it was you
were geographically constrained yeah if
you wanted to like be a vacuum [__] in
like 1990 people are going to kind of
look at you kind of weird and you're
gonna be on your own there somebody that
[__] vacuums that's not euphemism no oh
whereas today if you wanted to [__]
vacuums you could probably find an
online support group for it like they
will give you like the best vacuums to
have sex with and you can do that your
whole life you know but I'm just saying
that like you probably to some extent in
in like the 80s 90s before the internet
like you kind of have to like be talk to
your neighbors
all around you yeah whereas today you
have [__] this [__] 21 22 year old
kid who's leaking classified documents
to look cool to a bunch of people on
Discord bro what the [__] are you doing
yeah yeah it's like Jesus yeah
interesting yeah I am it's the it's the
freedom thing again so the conversation
I had in Qatar about masculinity
came down to the fundamental tension of
the guy I was speaking to said we need
to kind of blow up in the doors of what
it means to be a man because they're
constraining and some people who don't
fit into those existing paradigms are
made to feel like they're not a man or
they there's a Discord right there's
discontinuity between them my
realization was well yeah totally there
are certainly ways that you could
optimize for every single part of the
normal distribution right like right out
to zero and 100 but if you do do that
then it's the same as it being nothing
like if masculinity is everything it's
also nothing and the same thing goes for
like pick whatever uh stereotype or
archetype you want to have if you blast
the doors open completely you're saying
you need to work this out for yourself
there are no expectations there are no
guard rails nobody is coming to help you
and if you do use any of those
Traditions that have come from the past
you're gonna get attacked for it yes
precisely that's you being [__] like
there's like by the patriarchy or
[__] feminism or whatever yeah
there's like there's like two ways you
can go like one is you have like the
hyper Ridge should defined like this is
what it means to be man and nothing
outside can work and then you've got
like this like blow open everything and
it's like we can't say there's anything
about being a man correct and it's like
there is a third option that we were
kind of gunning for in like the late 90s
early 2000 felt like where it was like
listen we can actually blow open really
wide what it means to be a man or a
woman if you want to be a guy and paint
your nails and wear [__] makeup then
go for it and you know what a lot of
guys aren't going to be like you but
that's okay you just kind of like can do
your own thing but now it's not enough
to say this could be like really
different and that's okay now there has
to be kind of like this tear down of
like the the norm in the middle as well
like it can't just be that like you can
be unique and kind of do your own thing
and whatever now like everybody has to
be nothing in order to make it okay
instead of teaching people that like
sometimes you're just like it's okay to
be a little bit weird you can be weird
but now like weird is like a slur and
ask me no actually I'm not weird you're
just like heterosis normative and this
is like a horrible thing for society
saying okay [__] you yeah so optimizing
for the extremes and and sort of
bringing those in and making them part
of the norm one of the other things
again that I've been seeing thinking
about is how this relates to people's
um lack of capacity or desire or
motivation to deal with difficulty or
suffering or any kind of like anything
that requires you to push through hard
stuff to find meaning on the other side
of it and I guess it's kind of the same
like
why why bother if the system's rigged
against me if there is no meaning in
anything if having a family all of the
previous uh anchors that we would have
found meaning from in life if all of
those have been blown open then like
[__] it like if I do come up against any
kind of difficulty that should have been
snowplowed out of my way before I got
here
yeah there's a different there's a there
are two concepts it's called stress and
you stress where um yeah oh my God I'm
so glad a friend taught me this like two
years ago because I never heard this
before it was really one thing that's
really difficult for me is I love stress
it is very empowering to me when I'm in
stressful situations I feel like I'm
alive okay people have done it for my
career writing big things accusing me of
[__] it's very fun for me to navigate
those things like oh [__]
um and I learned this term a couple
years ago friend she read a book called
[__] it was like the power of stress or
something I don't remember something
like that but she said that well she
said the reason why you probably feel
this way is because there's two types of
stress there's stress which is bad for
you physiological is a horrible thing it
causes a lot of negative and that's
something like eustress which is similar
to what you're stressed but the
difference is for you stress you
stresses when you're going through
stressful things but you feel like
you've got tools to deal with it and
stress is when you feel helpless and
despite how weird my upbringing is in my
life whatever I've never felt helpless
I've always felt like if something is
[__] I'm the only person who's going
to do anything about it I have to do
something we'll figure it out you know
I'm gonna have to work [__] 16 hours
a day seven days a week but we're gonna
we'll do something you know so for me
stressful situations are like okay it's
challenging but like I gotta work my way
through it but when kids don't have the
ability to learn how to manage or deal
with stressful environments then stress
becomes this like horrific
all-encompassing like blanket of
Darkness that falls on you and you're
like [__] I can't do anything I'm
paralyzed I don't know what to do like
at least so much and like they have no
idea how to deal with any of the advice
so yeah I agree that like people today
like if the adversity is not plowed out
of their way they basically turn into
these like helpless
frumps of nothing that I can't deal with
anything yeah why is that let's call it
fragility to stress why is that
um so prevalent in some corners of the
left do you think
um because it seems to me that the right
almost identifies itself as being the
even if it's not true even if this isn't
how they show up it's how they state
which is we like I'm built for hard
things everyone's Tim Kennedy with a
[__] knife behind his back
that doesn't seem to be the same on the
left at the moment and that to me seems
like a self-defeating ideology because
you're making yourself inherently more
fragile and less capable of dealing with
anything that you come up against
including the ideology on the opposite
side of the aisle that you say that you
[__] hate yeah I I think that people
on the left have to adopt my ideology I
think that you have to teach people
about the unfairness of systems and and
all of that I think it's good to know
it's going to be aware of it but you
also have to treat people as individuals
at the end of the day and tell them like
Hey listen like despite how unfair the
world is or whatever you can't sit there
and cry about it you have to do
something about it so you know
um
like class analysis should be like a
medical diagnosis when you go to the
hospital and you get a diagnosis for
some sort of like medical ailment or
medical disease or whatever are you from
the left are you from the right sure the
reason why you get the diagnosis the
only reason why we have diagnosis for
things is because there's a treatment
plan right so if you talk to somebody
you say like Hey listen you're part of
this class and you might be affected in
this way this is what you have to do
about it right it has to come paired
with that piece of advice it can't just
be you're part of this classic you're
[__] you're part of this so like
you'll never get it you know right it's
gonna be like okay well you have to
you've got this so keep this in mind do
this you know
um I I notice it when it comes to like
mental ailments people will do that a
lot like on Twitter people are like oh
like I've got OCD I've got ADHD blah
blah they'll say these things like okay
what are you doing about it and it's
like what do you mean what am I doing
about it it's like well what the [__] is
the point of knowing you have this thing
you're not [__] do anything about it
right or when people say things like oh
I can't do that because of my ADHD and I
was like what do you mean you can't do
that because you're 80 if you have ADHD
do something about it what the [__] why
would you just use that as an excuse to
do nothing you know what is your vision
or if you were able to try and give some
advice to liberals in general you know
you're coming from the left as far as
I'm concerned you're the most reasonable
person that I listen to the period now
I'm just gonna go look close I dude I
really I really appreciate the stuff
that you put out I think both me and a
bunch of people from Austin who would
not really listen to anybody that was
coming from that side of a talking point
and like [__] Destiny keeps on
getting these things right as far as I
can see and even if it's not the
background that I come from like [__]
yeah like that's reasonable it's well
balanced it's understanding it's agentic
it's aspirational which I think is
really really [__] important like if
the vision that you put forward for
somebody is to be this like cooked
victim that is completely at the mercy
of the world around you
who who re like how are you selling this
to almost anybody that wants to have a
Grand Vision for their life what is the
first off what's your prediction for the
way that the left foot not what do you
want to happen but given where we're at
the progressive eating itself etc etc is
that going to correct self-correct and
move more back toward this Vision that
you've got and something from the late
90s early 2000s or is this continuing to
run away with itself into an extreme I
think it's kind of sad but I think the
left I think the progressives are
starting to fall apart I don't think
whatever comes the next will call
themselves Progressive like I still do
but I have to qualify it a lot because I
don't want people to instantly assume a
bunch of things about me
um if you've been watching it online
have you seen like The Young Turks
correct yeah tell me explain to people
briefly what's happened with The Young
Turks
um well if you've watched my stream
they're basically going through what I
went through three years ago where um it
was really funny because like um Anna
was saying on uh on the anchor she's
like I'm tired of working with these
leftists they come on this show they
build up a big audience and then they
leave the show and they act like they
never heard you before they start
trashing you and I've I've without any
names I've had people do the exact same
thing to me and it's funny because like
if I
um if I leave somebody's show
and then somebody asks me something in
the future I think I've had people ask
me about you because I think that you're
a bit more into some of the manosphere
red pill stuff than I think I am I think
so yeah in terms of some of your takes
and I want to say people can find it if
I'm wrong but like people ask me about
you
um if I see a clip of you I'm gonna say
I talked to him in a podcast he seems
like a pretty reasonable guy we might
have some disagreements here that I
think that would be about my take but I
feel like other people will come away
like imagine you're me and then I'm like
a random leftist somebody would show me
one clip of you and they'd be like oh he
probably [__] hates women that guy is
just a [__] piece of [__] and it's
like you talk to this guy you were on
this guy's show or sometimes you had
extended relations with these people but
as soon as you do one thing wrong it's
like the backlash is [__] insane and
it happens so much with progressives
where for Anna um it was over two big
things one is she had something to say
about homeless people uh because there's
some homeless guy in Seattle or San
Francisco that attacked a woman on the
street this happened a few years uh I
think a year or two ago oh yeah it was a
huge thing and she was like this is
crazy this guy should be in jail and all
the progressors like you can't just put
homeless people in jail there are
unhoused neighbors and Blah Blah Blah's
like oh my god there was that big thing
that was a year or two ago with Anna and
then recently it was over the um
The Young Turks are like avowedly
Progressive like these guys aren't even
like Democrats these guys are like
Progressive yeah holy [__] Purity spiral
kicking in yet again so like I don't
think that's gonna lie if you're getting
like The Young Turks breaking off your
movement like I don't think that's gonna
last for very much longer and again like
you said like these people have like no
[__] tenacity to deal with anything
so they all eat themselves alive they
all have very low ability to cope or
deal with adversity they're just like a
horrible yeah we'll get back to Destiny
in one minute but first I need to tell
you about whoop whoop is the best
fitness tracker that I've ever found I
used it for four and a half years long
before they ever sponsored the podcast
and it literally tracks everything your
heart rate variability your resting
heart rate how much you're breathing
throughout the night your recovery your
sleep your training absolutely
everything not only that but it spits
out a bunch of suggestions about how you
can improve yourself how you can make
better choices with regards to your
training and your rest also there is no
joining fee a free first month and a
30-day money-back guarantee so you can
buy it for free try it for free and if
you do not like it after 29 days they'll
give you your money back head to
join.woop.com Modern wisdom that's
join.woop.com
modern wisdom someone called you out
left
I didn't even know that was a thing it's
oh no when you say someone are you
talking about the squirrel No someone
replied to me on Twitter oh they
basically said um interesting
conversation you had about such and such
recently uh would love to see someone
from the left take and I replied and
said interesting I've got Destiny coming
on in a week's time like basically
you're not a real leftist or all left
was like a way to discard the fact that
I was bringing you on that wasn't left
enough I didn't even know that all left
was a thing there's a weird squirrel
Twitter account that calls me alt left
but she says that because I'm like not
conservative but I'm like racist and
transphobic and bigoted in a nazian blah
blah so I don't know if that was a
reference to that or not Purity spiral
kicks in again so okay so that's you've
said that you think that this
Progressive thing is not going to be
able to sustain it like people are
getting a little tired of like the crazy
cancellation [__] yes and the left
obviously all eating themselves alive
and they don't they haven't gotten any
political power it's inherently
self-defeating right if every everybody
is constantly looking for whoever is
next going to be shaved off the outside
of the Purity spiral
it's so self-contradictory that after a
little while everybody has to abandon it
because everyone has been everyone has
had the finger pointed at them or
themselves yeah but I mean like I feel
like everybody does this I feel like
every time a group gets like massively
in power they can't help but like eat
themselves alive I feel like I remember
this in um
[__] was it was McCain Palin 2008
um oh maybe you were in here country
where yeah where Republicans get like in
power and then they start like eating
themselves alive because they're
starting to cut off because like this
guy is like a Mormon and this guy is
like kind of weird but so I mean like
they just it feels like any time a group
gets in power they start that weird
[__] like purity testing where it's
like you can't be part of this group and
you don't do this and uh but we're
seeing that on the right as well to some
degree right a little bit although for I
think for different reasons kind of
trump is [__] insane and I think that
that like I think there's like a unique
set of things that are causing the
problem the big difference is the number
of tenants on in the United States on
the left for as much as progressives
might be powerful on Twitter or in
schools or whatever they represent a
very small portion of the democratic
party they don't really have very much
political power there's like four people
in the house and like that said but on
the right Trump is their like extremist
guy and that's like [__] half the
Republican party will follow Trump off a
cliff right now so they have like a very
unique situation where they're trying to
deal with that at the moment I think why
didn't the Trump indictment get more
media coverage I thought it would have
been I mean it was not not covered but I
figured it should have been something
absolutely [__] massive and it didn't
seem that way to me
um it was massive for a day but our new
Cycles are very quick now it's like we
get over [__] in like one or two days
um also think diamonds are kind of like
boring it wasn't like anything like
super spicy
um even though people have been saying
they were gonna be pretty boring and
they came out and they're like no so
um but then it's also like Trump is just
very fatiguing there's so many like
insane things involving him all the time
that at some point it's like hard to
care anymore you're just like oh yeah
like even the whole indictment the
things surround really like if we were
to go back like five years or six or
seven years like the most surprising
thing would be like could you imagine
having a president of the United States
that was [__] porn stars behind us
like recently had a [__] child's
wife's back
that's like an insane thing could you
imagine if Obama had done that there is
no set incredibly High yeah yes yeah or
incredibly loaded and how you view it
yeah so it's like so now it's like oh
Trump did a thing I was like okay
whatever you know what about the the
fact if this Progressive thing isn't
viable because the progressives are
telling people how to live their lives
are the ones that are killing themselves
and on antidepressant was it like some
insane percentage of Jesus like 50 of I
think liberal women at a certain age
have been like on some type of like
antidepressants like Jesus yes if that's
the you should live your life this way
well come on like proof's in the pudding
this doesn't really seem to be growing
particularly much corn have you seen
that have you seen the Twitter video
where somebody's like it's time to like
rise up my communist Brothers we need
guns and [__] and then it starts playing
um some like [__] 90s pop punk emo
song and it's just like tweet after
tweet of like uh like oh [__] I have to
show this to you later it's really
[__] funny sorry okay I'm going to
show you this people in the oldest one
I'm talking about okay okay so if if the
progressive thing isn't viable does that
mean that the Trad thing's viable
uh no absolutely not absolutely not and
this is one this is kind of what this is
what frustrates me so much is that
Progressive are obviously [__] lost
but then like conservatives or some of
the Trap people like okay we're gonna go
back to being tread no you're not we're
never getting rid of abortion we're
never getting rid of birth control women
are working in ways that they never have
before and they have so much control
over reproduction that the world has
fundamentally changed and whatever we go
forward with in the world it has to take
into account those two realities so
anybody that's walking out here
expecting that men can get women with
paychecks or by being Alpha you're
everything you're saying is doesn't
matter anymore you're talking about a
world that doesn't exist anymore
um and anybody that's talking about like
very traditional roles in terms of like
who's earning more money in the house or
whatever you're probably not relevant
anymore so we have to carve out some
world in the future where we have some
idea of a masculine or male archetype
that's compatible with the fact that
your wife might be earning or even out
earning you right that has to be a thing
because once Pandora's Box is open in
terms of like the reproduction [__] and
the working [__] it's just not going to
go away women are going back to to what
they were before it's not going to
happen and it sucks because like it
would be interesting to see a lot of
like Trad talks in that direction
there's only you know what there's only
one person I've ever heard give a good
take on trade relationships and it was
[__] Ben Shapiro did you see Ben
Shapiro's conversation with Lex Friedman
bits of it uh I come from a very
conservative background I grew up
Catholic and when I listen to
traditional people talk about male
female relationships
the fact that the woman was staying in
the house it was always something that
was spoken about with the utmost amount
of respect
um a woman might stay in the house but
like this this whole the way that like
the father is the leader like it's kind
of true but it was always with
consultation and consent and Cooperative
yes always and the way that people talk
about it today is with such [__]
derision and hatred for women and like
oh yeah like she stays in the house the
man is the leader the man is in charge
and it's like even the sitcoms before
even when the fathers were highly
competent show that the woman was very
much an important figure Bill Cosby was
like was he a doctor or a dentist and
like his wife like even he was scared of
his wife um in The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air
um the uncle
um Uncle Phil was a [__] high powered
attorney lawyer and his wife was very
scary right that was always the case the
way we rolled that forward into the
period where men became the Clowns the
Homer Simpsons of the Wolves the Peter
Griffins of the world it's even more
it's the it's the competent one she's
the one that's balanced she runs the
home she runs the man yeah even in a
traditional sense so like when the tribe
people talk about this is one of my big
complaints about like red pillars this
is always so much adversity between men
and women rather than like cooperation
so any Trad thing going forward
um I don't think there's anything wrong
with Trad stop some of it is fun
um like some masculine feminine roles
can be fun in the bedroom out of the
bedroom whatever but it just has to be
done with respect to where the kind of
like the labor market is and the
education and everything and the
Reproductive Rights are today because
that's not going to change so it has to
incorporate that going forward how do
you square the circle of uh women's I'm
going to call it over uh success but
women's increased success in both
education employment and status with the
fact that on average women want to date
a man who's as educated or more as
employed or more as status women want to
but that has changed pretty dramatically
um I wish I had this set in hand but I
want to say it was like 20 years ago it
was like it was like 45 of women would
never consider dating a guy that was
earning more than that was earning less
than them and I think that number has
fallen out of like 29 and it'll probably
continue to change over time but um yeah
that's going to be something changing
going forward the
this might just be my capitalist mindset
but but like I always when people email
me and they always say like Destiny I
want to start like this business I want
to start this website like what's your
piece of advice to me the one thing that
I always ask somebody is
if you want to start a small business
first question in my opinion you should
be able to answer is why would somebody
use your thing over anything else if you
don't have a Snappy response to that
then quit go do something else you need
to know a media like they want to use my
thing or watch me because I can offer
this unique thing and I think you should
approach everything in life like that so
if you're a man and you're approaching a
woman and you're trying to say like okay
I want to be in a relationship with
moment well what do you have to offer
what's the value add it can't just be a
paycheck because women are working it
can't just be dick because she's got
birth control and Tinder it has to be
something more than that and people
aren't equipping men I think to have a
good answer to that question
um you know you can talk about the alpha
hyper masculine stuff but like to be
that masculine you're talking about like
one percent of guys you know you're
talking about like even six figure
depending on where you're at might not
necessarily be the [__] you know you're
talking about a very very small
percentage so I feel like a lot of
people aren't equipping men like to be
able to like have that value ad for
women what are some of the value adds
then if it's outside of providing
resources employment Etc there's going
to be a I'm gonna trigger the [__] out
of a lot of people saying this here's
how I view like The World Is Gone okay
women
um were feminine men were masculine and
women over the past 20 30 40 years have
done a really good job at kind of like
capturing and incorporating a whole
bunch of masculine traits okay women are
working they have a lot of Independence
they're kind of managing their [__]
they've done a really good job at
incorporating that while also still
being feminine some people say I make
you less feminine but like they still
have like the feminine traits too they
can take care of houses they can clean
and all they should maybe some of them
can't cook whatever
um for men I feel like because of the
way that we were raised the way we're
socialized or whatever we still kind of
have our masculine things like men can
work jobs and do that and they do
sometimes even to their detriment uh for
example like over the coronavirus
pandemic
um
men were staying home more than women to
continue working to provide their for
their families right so the education
Gap grew even more during the pandemic
seven times more men dropped out of
college during covert than women yeah to
maintain like households and everything
right so men are still working they're
doing that but the problem is men
haven't Incorporated any of the feminine
traits into their like psyche so women
are now like these like Alpha Omega like
masculine feminine creatures that are
now going through yeah they're going
through the world and men are like okay
well um I'm like I'm very masculine and
it's like okay well can you be
communicative do you have emotional
intelligence can you do any of these
things things that tradition like guys
don't give a [__] about because like I
don't like I don't need to be
emotionally intelligent yeah you need my
money to survive [__] what are you
gonna do right and now she's like well I
have enough money [__] you I was like
okay so one of the one of the things
that I could see is a complication or a
wrinkle there is that the sex drive and
desire
for women from men is so great that even
a woman who has ingrained her masculine
is still going to be attractive to the
guy for sure I'm not convinced that a
guy who has embodied his feminine
becomes more attractive to a woman
especially when you have this disparity
with regards to earning an education
I think it's possible I just think we
have like really weird and toxic ideas
of like what feminine means especially
from like red pill or manuscript faces I
run into this all the time that for
instance it's oh man okay here's a
really really insane example to me that
I hear okay I don't know if you've said
this but a lot of red pillars say this
thing where it's like if you're ever you
should never ever be emotionally
vulnerable to a woman because she might
never ever said that I'm not just to get
it out there so that you understand my
positioning within the world of men's
advice I'm not a part of the manosphere
I never have been I'm not red pill I
never have gosh I gotcha okay I am so
blue pilled that I'm cooked in the eyes
of the manosphere and I'm so bigoted
that I'm a misogynist in the eyes of
Guardian readers guys so I split the
difference straight down the middle you
have okay okay and when it comes to the
emotional vulnerability thing
that is a story that is told by men who
have only ever been in relationships
with women who haven't got good uh
emotional control there are women out
there who will and I've been in
relationships with some of them that so
vulnerability as a strength sure even
yeah or even so people will say that
like if you're ever emotionally
vulnerable she might leave you right but
if you're like and if you're an
emotionally intellectual man you know
emotional intelligence
um emotional vulnerability is one of the
biggest tools a manipulator can use
totally [__] mind [__] somebody
because showing limited Master
vulnerability can get a woman incredibly
obsessed with you and any guy that like
is like a manipulative person knows that
well think about what the push and pull
is right the high-powered Boss [__]
female lawyer that wants to be tied up
and domed by her husband on the night
time why is that hot why is that
interesting because of the polarity
sometimes yeah the same the same thing
goes for the guy that can be vulnerable
on one side but is also super competent
you know going out there and doing his
thing is able to show strength but show
something else too yes yes absolutely
the polarity is really important and I
know this in my life because I'm online
I'm like hyper aggressive Ultra debate
bro you know very uh I'll say
Massachusetts yeah like a very yeah I'm
very very aggressive but then um did you
say want to be pegged in the bedroom no
nice try
um but like on a personal level if
somebody sees me and I'm like a bit more
emotionally vulnerable or maybe more
open to somebody it feels like very
special it feels very earned like oh
cool like and every woman I've talked to
I have never in my life had a woman tell
me like God I wish you would just be
more aggressive to me personally it's
always like I wish you would open up
more I wish you'd be like more blah blah
blah and it's like I try I have issues
with someone it's like yeah but um that
just that's an idea of like what it
means to be more feminine but every time
you say that's like a red pill or
whatever they're like oh you want to
just like cry and sob and blah blah blah
no that's being a [__] child okay
think about that uh it's better to be a
warrior in a garden than a gardener in a
war quote that everybody loves to throw
around okay turn that on its head and
say it's exactly the same thing but in
this instance being a warrior is being
able to integrate your emotions yeah but
okay is it not better to have an
understanding of your emotions being
connection with them and then choose to
deploy them when you think that it's
appropriate and be able to open up as
opposed to being like no this is just a
black box that me and no one else is
ever going to look at and I'm going to
die at age 70 because of [__] like
emotional spiritual death yeah
yeah it's just it's really dumb like
that having that emotional intelligence
is so so important it's the number one
thing I need to work on in my life that
I'm like actively like working a lot
with my wife even is like trying to be
like a little bit more emotionally
communicative because I've grown up like
as a very stoic person but um I think I
think that every woman wants like that
type of communication with a guy on a on
a healthier level but a lot of men don't
learn it because we don't really
communicate with ourselves like that
um there are some women out there I
think that would see I I've been around
them ones that uh will say if I see my
partner make a joke that doesn't land I
like I cringe inside my ovary shrivel up
inside the hyper hyper attuned to a man
it might be there are also some women
that only did guys with super huge
forearms but I mean like there's always
going to be like the exceptions of
course whatever you say yeah well there
you go yeah but I mean like for in
general like being a bit more
emotionally intelligent and
communicative is pretty important as a
guy I think you have to you need to be
especially to understand like women like
you need to be more in tune with
yourself to see it like in other people
too remember as well the the biggest
predictors when it comes to longevity in
a relationship are
emotional stability conscientiousness
growth mindset those are the one they
have the best predictive power
the stuff like
um traditional attractiveness
education level education level is uh
controlled for a little bit but earnings
have none of this but that's not what
you're optimizing for and this is where
I think that in trying to integrate some
of the insights I talk about a ton on
the show but saying okay what's your
outcome goal here is your outcome goal
to be able to [__] as many girls as
possible or to sleep with one guy and
never catch feels or is it to try and
have a flourishing relationship that's
going to make you feel fulfilled and not
mean that you die alone at like [__]
75 with a ton of dogs yeah like
what are we optimizing for yeah yeah and
like I talk about
like in my opinion there's like people
treat it as like there's two boxes
you've got femininity and masculinity
and then like you try to like maximize
women femininity men masculinity and I
always feel like there's like three
bucks you got like femininity maturity
and masculinity we all need to work on
maturity and like femininity masculine
there's like really fun things on the
side you know if you've got a guy who is
incredibly intelligent he's a hard
worker he's really driven he's in tune
with everything and he's like he's you
know tries his best like that's awesome
if he's also like six four that's a huge
that's a bonus it's like a fun thing on
the side or if you've got a girl who's
got like you know she's got all of her
stuff figured out and she like big boobs
like that's cool like the masculine
feminine things are like really fun
things on the side and they can like be
really fun things to play with but
that's not like the main driving
contributing successes in these
relationships I think you know think
about what current dating optimizes for
though it optimizes for those easily
displayable objective metrics of success
it's the Rolex on your Tinder profile
it's the number of followers that you've
got it's the blue tickets the car it's
the size of the boobs it's a lip filler
Etc yeah and for [__] men today it's
[__] trt I can't I think guys are
heading towards a world where we're
finally going to start to see how
negative social media can affect you in
the way that has been affecting women
for so long okay why because all these
[__] now okay all these guys I
don't give a [__] 99 of Fitness
influencers are on [__] gear and trt
counts as gear now okay every
[__] does I haven't seen so many
videos so many things you guys like oh
these are like my six month uh results
for like lifting or whatever and these
guys are like they're lean as [__]
they're getting huge and it's like oh
like I'm 27 Lifting for the first time
in five months this is my like bro
really so why is that what's that got to
do with the female impact of social oh
because I think for women I think women
see like a whole bunch of like this is
what women should look like you should
be this and that and like everybody's
using like filters and lip filler and
and
for guys it's like yeah it's gonna be
next oh well if you're a guy and you've
been Lifting for six months you should
look like this and it's like no shot
yeah interesting and I've seen more and
more of those like pop up everywhere now
where it's almost like and because trt
is so accessible these days have you
ever had your levels done have you ever
checked it yeah they're very low what do
you think the last time I checked is 308
wow that is low yeah yeah that's like
nearly subclinical I think like it's
like I've heard the Rangers number from
300 to 1 000 or you've got eight you're
playing with eight yeah or 350 to 1000
so I'm already below it but I don't have
any of the symptoms of low T so like uh
yeah I'm drunk dude I'm in the gym I'm
doing my best but yeah well played um we
were talking before we got started about
sort of some of the challenges of how uh
people observe success especially in the
modern world you have a lot of young
people that watch the stuff that you do
you probably communicate with a bunch of
them either like through stream or
privately as well what do young people
believe will make them happy in the
modern world but actually won't what are
some of the myths that they're told
about sort of finding meaning and
fulfillment in life
um I feel like this is a really hard one
for me because I think my mind works in
a pretty unique way and that I am a very
individual not powered by other people's
uh approval kind of mindset it's helped
me a lot in the streaming world because
I've been able to deal with a lot of
people hating me at one point in time
um so I'll say this cautiously but I
feel like chasing other people's
approval is is a it's a bad way to live
because it's very much like live by the
sword Die By The Sword type of thing to
where if other people's approval makes
you feel really good about yourself
other people's disapproval is going to
make you hate yourself you're
Outsourcing yourself with a self-worth
to the throne yeah I've always been big
on like self-esteem and self-confidence
are called that because they come from
yourself like if you're a self-confident
person but only because you've got a
huge support network and everybody
around you is telling you a good job
it's not that's not true yeah you like
self-confidence is like I want to do a
thing and everybody's calling me [__]
[__] but I'm gonna do it anyway
because I think it's the right thing to
do like that's like self-confidence
that's what you really want you know to
some extent you want to be like a
narcissist but um yeah so I think that
um
trying to find things that give you like
a genuine source of joy that like give
you like a deep sense of meaning that
feel really good for me it was music it
was music it's really fun to do musical
things I don't care if other people like
it or don't that's a really cool hobby
for me no I yeah yeah I don't give a
[__] and I don't like impress anybody
um those types of things are really
important if you spend your whole life
living by other people's opinions of you
you'll die by other people's opinions of
you yeah does a desire sometimes that I
notice in myself especially if I'm in a
like a zero-sum uh back by T mentality
where I'm trying to get one over on
somebody else that I'll find myself
almost trying to win at a game that I
know that they care about but I don't so
let's say that uh I get a ton of
pushback on the podcast or on something
that I've done uh to do with the fact
that I'm way too blue pilled uh and
I'll think okay well I'm bigger than you
like I'm in better condition I'm leaner
than you I'm stronger than you I'll
better go to the gym and this will
motivate me more to go to the gym and
it's like no hang on a second like
you're playing a game that you know that
those people value but it's not your
game like where does this come from yeah
so you can almost find a way where
people take the desires of those around
them
import them in and then say Oh I'm going
to do all of these different things
which involve winning at everybody
else's game without ever working out
what the game is that I care about
without working out what would genuinely
fulfill me yeah and then when you look
back and you think oh what is the list
of accomplishments or Pursuits that I've
gone through and you just see Shadows of
everyone else you know what I mean kind
of really hard to think because I just
watched in the past day or two something
about like how when other people like
invoke hatred in you you're basically
letting them control you in your life
yeah yes
um like a guiding principle that I've
used for my life is there are things
that I want
to do and I have to be a certain person
to do those things so for me success is
like improving myself and kind of
gradually sculpting and building myself
to be that person and the only person I
can compare myself to is myself because
everybody's got like a unique starting
point Jordan Peterson um yeah maybe it
might
um Jordan Peterson a lot of good things
to say before like 2018 I think before
his brain broke honestly truly he really
did a lot of good things to say
um but yeah like that it's truly like
the most important person to compare
yourself to is yourself it's they he has
the same starting position as you he is
all the same things going for him and
against him and as long as you're doing
better than you were yesterday like
you're making improvements and that's
like the best way to live I think one of
the problems you would have there
especially from current Progressive
ideology would be that doesn't take into
account all of the challenges that we're
facing systemically and so on you go
well no it does because both versions of
you are facing the exact same problems
yeah but it is so disempowering again
this sort of everything is outsourced
everything is systemic the world is
against you uh I can see how
it must be very disempowering it must be
very disempowering to be somebody who
you know there's a how much is a
political ideology heritable it's like
25 point I think it's like point six or
point seven it's like very high like 60
70 okay very very horrible yeah right so
my point being that you are basically
working from a genetic backup of what's
going on here
and you can have a world in which you
want to have the driven individual
agency personal sovereignty all of that
[__] but you also happen to hold this
political view
that doesn't really seem to work and it
seems to be a lot of friction going on
it's there is friction I don't know how
to explain it but you there there is a
way you you there's got to be a way to
do it you have to know that you're an
outlier with this I know but like so for
instance right I've been taking the gym
very very seriously for the past like
six seven months I've been taking it
pretty serious for the past two years
but very seriously for the best six
seven months good man okay when I go to
the gym okay it's hard okay and it's
hard to progress and I'm probably
starting off at a low level muscle and
I'm probably taking a little bit longer
to progress on my lifts than I would
otherwise and when I go to the gym
things have to exist in my mind at the
same time one is okay progress is going
to be a little bit slower than me okay I
know that I understand that okay I
accept that but I still have to try as
hard as I can those two things can't
counteract each other and if you're if
you're not careful
the problem is that like
in a way
308t for me is it nanoliters per decided
grammar what the [__] whatever it is
right 308 for me is like the liberal
mindset and being as big as possible is
the conservative mindset right if I let
that 308 number Define me why the [__]
should I even bother going to the gym
I'm never going to be as big as I could
have been if I would have started
lifting at 15 I'm never going to be as
big as a guy willing to do trt I'm never
going to be as big as a guy that's just
Natty more more testosterone than me
[__] it why should I waste my time but
if I go to the conservative route right
okay well you know it's taken me six
months of grinding to get my squad up to
like 195 like another guy would be at
like 315 by now right I'm a [__] weak
piece of [__] why the [__] am I like you
know I can't I'm trying every day I'm
just gonna add five pounds of bar I'm
gonna injure myself like every two
months right that's like the
conservative mindset I was like [__] I
don't care about this immigration I'm
gonna work as hard as possible
um and it's funny because in a way um
through my kind of like lifting history
I've dealt with both of these right um
on the conservative mindset one is like
I don't know how many people realize
it's like pushing yourself in the gym
is actually really easy the hard thing
is the discipline to control your meals
your sleep and the routine that's the
really hard part it's really easy to go
to the gym and work out to get injured I
can do that all day and I've done that
before it's like [__] it 10 more pounds
on the bar [__] I just [__] snap my
[__] [__] I injure my shoulder [__] me
you know um and then on the liberal side
it's also where it's like [__] me my tea
is low anyway do I really need to be
shredded right I got a lot of [__]
money I [__] a lot of women I'm really
successful online who the [__] cares if
I have low tea and I don't yeah right so
there's I don't know how I do it I
managed to for most things in my life
somehow but you have to be able to
balance those two things out where it's
like I'm gonna work as hard as I
possibly can because I want to be the
best version of myself and I recognize
it how good I can be as myself might be
controlled by some environmental factors
but like there's the environmental
factors are saying that I can exist in
this range but in this range the the
conservative or personal factors are
going to determine where in this range
is all on you yeah exactly yeah
I really like that conception one other
thing I've been thinking about is um the
gap between opinions and deeds so for
pretty much all of human history the
thing that you said and the thing that
you did were very closely aligned right
you couldn't say a thing that didn't
involve you being there to say it there
wasn't some you know up until the
[__] printing press and who had
access to that so if you were going to
make a statement about how virtuous you
are about the way that you acted the way
that you showed up what time you got up
how many berries you caught what animal
you killed etc etc all of that would be
pretty much there in front for everyone
to stress test it is this real
now someone's opinions and their deeds
have been separated so much that all
that we see of people for the most part
are opinions you can be the most loving
caring partner the most well-balanced uh
liquid whatever pick whatever it is that
you say
that is able to be out front and no one
is really going to be able to stress
test what's happening behind this I
think is
fostering the performative empathy or
the ability for people to do a
performative empathy which is why I'm
always so skeptical when someone starts
talking online about proselytizing that
they're so
um caring about this particular maligned
group but then a couple of months later
you see them throw the same sort of
shade that they've just been protecting
someone against another group and this
is why hypocrisy and Scandal uh probably
I would say the like the most cat-nip
content on the internet because what you
get to do is it's perfectly designed for
social media you have to say here is
something that happened before or that
they said before and here is something
that they've done now look at the
difference between these two things yeah
and that's again the performative
empathy thing to me makes a lot of super
Progressive commentators
seem disingenuous and I think
yeah it's it's a really hard one
um something that I said earlier in this
conversation was that our identity is
sharded between all of society like who
you are is not just who you are it's
what everybody thinks you are yes right
as much as that is a horrible concept
um this is something I've had to wrestle
with a lot of the past few years for me
personally my kind of idea was like
listen I'm gonna let my actions speak
for themselves okay you might think I am
or whatever but like look at my history
uh and I realize that's actually not
good enough to where so like for
instance um I think I've done a lot of
like pretty cool political things in
terms of motivating my fan base to get
out in canvas for people uh personally
I've spent I think of this one over 150
000 housing people hotels getting people
to go to places campusing and all this
and spend a lot of my own money on this
and a lot of my own time with us I think
it's a really cool political project but
I'm not like here like bragging about it
or jerking off about it because you know
my interests speak themselves but I
noticed when I show up in certain areas
people are very very quick to be like oh
didn't you say this about Kyle
Rittenhouse didn't you make this joke
about black people didn't you say this
and it's like okay well I've also done
like this I don't know about that I
don't care anything okay well [__] so to
some extent like doing the pr and The
Virtue signaling is actually kind of
important and now I've had to be like
okay hey I did this thing I need you
guys to know that because in the future
I know you [__] are going to attack
me for every negative thing I said so I
need to be like front and center all the
positives so it's very irritating thing
to have to work because I I do agree to
some extent it's nice to like I want my
actions to speak for themselves but my
your actions don't say anything you have
to actually speak for them you know yes
it's very frustrating because there is
an asymmetry of attention placed on the
stuff that you do that is bad depending
on the agent that you're interacting
with because they don't want to give
attention to your good things you know
yes so you need to be upfront with those
sometimes well again but the problem is
in a world in which opinions and deeds
have been separated so much
your the level of uh how how heavily
you're going to be scrutinized and
discredited for the things that you say
it's like okay where's the [__]
receipts show me the homeless person
that you housed show me the images of
them going in there and then if you do
do that oh well you're capitalizing on
your like [__] social media altruism
project I think you just have to own
some of it that's what I say um like for
instance like for people that people
will do YouTube videos where they give
away money and homeless people they do
whatever and be like oh you're just
doing that for publicity and say well
it's not just no no [__] it say you are
doing it for publicity who the [__]
cares the homeless guy that's getting
the money doesn't give a [__] why you're
giving him money he doesn't give a [__]
if you're doing it for publicity right
he's getting good [__] and who cares if
you're getting publicity you're getting
publicity doing a good thing who cares
if that's the only reason you're doing
it the only reason that I donated a
million dollars from malaria research
and [__] Africa is because I know who
cares fine that's [__] fine you
should get good attention for it I think
people should just own it but people are
so scared of being like vain or whatever
um I mean being vain in those ways I
think is fine like if you're vain
because you're a philanthropist or
you're vain but because like oh like I
I'm entered you know 550 young boys and
got them out of like prison into like
okay yeah who cares brag about it be you
know whatever you want about I think
it's okay to do that but yeah
I wonder whether
I wonder what's going to happen moving
forward I wonder whether it's going to
be the case that we need good deeds to
be done so that people are going to be
given more leeway with that because the
amount of scrutiny that does get applied
to this stuff and the amount of like
it's a disincentive if you were to say
everybody the post about doing good
things online should quite rightly be
like well yeah well done you did go and
do that
but this sort of culture of cynicism and
and satire and like sardonic commentary
that we spoke about earlier on seems to
kind of take that away this is yeah I
don't think any of that actually matters
at all um we talked about this earlier I
think one or two bad things is enough to
undo literally everything you've done
like Anna is a really great example for
The Young Turks this is like the largest
or was the I think still is the largest
like Progressive left-leaning Channel
um I think chank with Kyle kolinsky
helped start and fund the Justice
Democrats and everything
um none of that matter she made one or
two bad statements and now people like
[__] Anna like I'm done with her I was
like what the [__] do you know what the
peak end rule is have you heard of this
nope okay so it's a cognitive bias that
was discovered by Eamon taversky and
Daniel Kahneman khanman wrote Thinking
Fast and Slow uh during a colonoscopy
every minute the patients were given a
rating and they could rate how painful
the experience was then one day later
they were asked to write how painful it
was and six months later asked to do the
same what they discovered was that there
are two parts of an experience that
determined the
um reflective pain that someone
remembers and it was the peak how high
it got at any point throughout and the
end so they actually discovered that
they could change the remembered pain of
the colonoscopy by extending the length
of the colonoscopy at the end and
bringing the pain was basically how much
it was moved if you get moved a lot it's
a lot of pain if it doesn't get moved
much it's not so they had a control to
be able to work out so what they did was
they found if they just left the little
scope thing in the ass for an extra
couple of minutes at the end and it
wasn't very painful in retrospect it was
half as painful the memory was half as
painful so it's called the peak Andrew
interesting I came up with something
called the peak hate rule okay which is
basically that every single content
creator on the Internet is defined by
their most egregious transgression and
their most recent transgression so uh
Jordan Peterson is both a transphobe for
you know the bill c-16 thing that he
both became most famous for and I don't
know what he said Sports Illustrated
let's say like that's his thing uh
hassanabi would be most famous for uh
911 yep and whatever
donating to Amazon I think was a big
thing the Amazon Union thing do you know
what I mean yeah okay it's so
interesting you say this um because you
got there in such a different way but I
actually won a million percent agree I
have two different things that I apply
this to
um one uh has to do with streaming okay
and I said something with a lot of
people they'll get into a very dramatic
situation and online when you're in
drama I don't know if you've ever been
like at the the receiving end of like
hey mob online not yet when it happens
to happen yeah it feels like the end of
the world
and I always tell somebody my saying is
like people only remember you for your
last three streams whatever the [__] you
do don't stop streaming I know it sucks
and it feels good but keep streaming and
in two or three days people will [__]
forget but if you stop now this is your
defining moment and you will never come
back and that rule has worked 100 of the
time I've known people they got into a
big drama and like [__] I can't and they
take a little bit of break off or
whatever and they're done they can't do
it they can't go back yeah because it
was wait what'd you say patriarch
patriarch we see oh we see the defense
yeah the Deep fake gun yeah yeah he took
a big long break which just allowed
everyone to kind of get sucked into it
did he get back to streaming he was a
really big streamer though right massive
time I think he's got it he might go but
he might be able to break it just but
like in general I've known a lot of
people who it's usually for like the
mid-sized people they'll take that break
and then they might try to come back
like once but then that wave of hate
Flash and then they quit and they just
they could not to your entire career
yeah and they can't come back and they
get [__] by it and I'm like just keep
sure I've had like really dramatic
things and I had uh I went to an I went
to an MLG I got into a super situation
MLG uh Pro gaming tournament like 11
years ago okay really dramatic I did
stupid things uh girl hack my Twitter
account post my dick on my Twitter just
very dramatic very stupid thing um and I
was home I streamed the next day I'm
like [__] it straight in the next day
people made jokes whatever two or three
days later as dramatic in a sense people
were like okay we're done we're through
it right just keep streaming keep
streaming no matter what the [__]
happens keep streaming in two or three
days everyone'll forget what about how
to deal with it interpersonally let's
say that it's not necessarily A content
creator or it might be uh it could be
someone that just does something that
causes the world to point a lot of
fingers at them how do you like where do
you go within yourself do you spend time
with friends are you do you reframe it
in a particular way do you you just have
to keep giving New Impressions of you I
think
um so I get I had two examples one was
the professional level the second thing
is have you ever heard of the saying um
you never get a second chance to make a
first impression first impression so
important something that I found this is
especially true like on dates when
you're making a new impression on
somebody in my personal opinion the
first impression is largely irrelevant
what really matters is like the last
like 30 to 60 General person yeah it's
like if you go on a date and something
is like really fun and exciting right at
the beginning and like the last like two
hours are kind of like boring that's
what they're gonna remember you for but
if you're going to date and it's kind of
starts awkward it's whatever blah blah
blah but you end on a high note you're
that's so much better it's so good to do
that like just end on like a really
positive impression of you or something
and the the next time that's what
they're gonna have on their head more
than like remembering the first
impression I find personally people
don't remember First Impressions that
much they definitely remember the last
interaction they've had with you though
so yeah keep having impressions of
people somebody had a negative
impression if you had another thing like
treat keep trying to have positive
interactions obviously be careful with
this I'm not saying that like if you
give a bad impression go stalk somebody
at work and try to like make them see
you differently or whatever but uh yeah
you can [__] up but like don't let that
be your last moment with somebody we're
like oh I [__] up I'm not going to
talk to them again because that's all
they're ever gonna remember of you yes I
really like that and I like the fact
that we've come at this from it couldn't
be more different very very different
very different angles uh how worried are
you about being replaced by a gpt6
do you think is it gonna take six the
five isn't gonna do it I didn't [__]
know I didn't know but like I spoke to
Rob wiblin guy from 80 000 hours podcast
like big in EA effective altruism
existential risk uh and he basically
said that he's like looking toward the
Twilight of his career as he winds down
to be replaced by
like robot Rob or [__] like Rob chat
or something
is there a is there something unique
about human creation do you think that's
not going to be able to be replicated by
chat GPT
down the line like within the next let's
say within the next 10 years
uh I think that AI is going to force us
to confront a lot of very uncomfortable
aspects of humanity that we have never
thought about before or maybe like
philosophers have thought about but
normal people haven't and I don't know
what answers we're going to decide what
like what's some examples
um what is art it's a very very
um so here on the broadest sense
computers are calculators and we thought
for a long time that that's all they can
do but things like creativity
inspiration that's exclusively the
domain of humans the computer's not
going to be able to create a beautiful
art piece make a symphony blah blah blah
right they clearly they can becomes
mid-journey smashing that exactly
winning art contests and triggering
people and you know now if you ever hate
artists online the funniest thing to do
is when somebody posts a picture
um just go in the replies like this is
so beautiful what prompt did you use and
they'll lose their [__] mind
um but yeah the um clearly like if a
human can do it a computer can probably
do it and that's a very unsettling thing
for a lot of people to realize and
there's man I feel so bad there's a lot
of philosophers like philosophy of
language and existence and all this [__]
that they would have had a lot of
profound stuff to say but it's like what
is it like what does it mean for
something to even exist uh so for
instance like if I can start creating
stuff digitally Mike here's a question
okay I I can use an AI to make like a
fake person though right and now I can
get to the point almost where I can
convincingly create like dialogue comedy
like they can do like a full podcast and
you look at that and you're like okay
well that person's not real so it's not
the same and it's like well how real are
they compared to like me if we never
interact there's a lot of people watch
this will never interact with me real
life ever right is there a meaningful
difference between my existence and that
person's existence the person that isn't
even real everything's just like a p
zombie right a little bit yeah
um or even more like yeah like what does
it mean for a thing to even be that like
it's kind of a that's like a question
where it's like I'm really high but now
we actually have to really think about
that what does it mean for them to exist
what does it mean for them to be human
so what does it mean for you to be you
or what is it what is the threshold of
bandwidth and resolution at which you
need to be representing yourself for it
to actually be you does it need to be 95
because there are tons and tons of
things that you think and do that don't
come across externally right like your
inner world is a billion times richer
than what you represent to the outer
world and given the fact that all that
anybody else sees of you is what you
represent if you can find something that
does all of the outside stuff within you
know a couple of percents of accuracy
well what what does that mean that it
isn't you we basically there has to be
some axiomatic like foundational belief
that just says I'm gonna value something
because it's human but it's like
unjustified that's all it is because
like we can imagine a world where AI is
now creating art and maybe people like
okay well I only like imperfect art
because I know that it was made by a
human well an AI could make imperfect
artists and it's like okay well right at
some point it's like I like it just
because it's human made but there's like
no there's actually there's no
justification for that we thought there
was well it's beautiful because it's
Unique I can create anything well it's
beautiful because it's imperfect yeah I
can be imperfect well it oh you know
like so you think that it's just a
question of
um like finesse and and resolution and
and uh how much detail this thing can go
into that let's say I don't know whether
you listen to the episodes that uh Joe
Rogan like it was AI Joe Rogan did with
AI
the dude that runs open Ai and they're
talking it's a full hour-long podcast
and that speaking backward and forward
but there's some things that are missing
in there fewer errors than you would
expect the laughs aren't quite right you
know basically the degree of humanness
hasn't been fully replicated but if you
roll the sophistication of the program
forward it just starts to oh well what
you need is someone to get the word
wrong three times and forget someone
so the imperfect nature gets brought in
all right so are you are you out of a
job within 10 years
um I have no idea uh we got to figure
out how it's going to work then you've
got to exist within that Paradigm and
figure out how to work it because yeah I
mean obviously this is a thing that's
coming and you're not going to be able
to stop it because the technology is out
there it's freely available for people
to work on and iterate on
um I'm not going to pretend to predict
what the future is going to look like 10
years from now seven years ago I thought
that it was impossible something like
Trump could ever be president so why
would I try to predict the future of AI
yeah what about the danger of
AI created content online we obviously
had one two thousand one was a Cambridge
analytica 2016. yeah I think so yeah the
Facebook stuff yeah yeah so Cambridge
analytical for the people that don't
know was able to create I was able to
deploy very very targeted ads at super
small cohorts of people that they the
pain points of those people were
understood
at least the copy and the advert for
that had to be created by a real human
it would feed back up to the humans and
then you get some [__] shadowy cabal
of Vietnamese copywriters to come and
like do whatever the meme is that you
make and then you make a joke about
Hillary now you can do both ways for
this so you can find out which person
has which pain Point feed that into an
algorithm and have an individually
created piece of content that targets
precisely their unique personality to
nudge their preferences in one way or
another
surely that's [__] terrifying yeah of
course yeah I don't know what the I'm
not gonna be able to give you the answer
to that just just thinking about the
future demise of the internet I suppose
as well you know with social media what
humans have been trying to do and this
is what audience capture is at its heart
is they're trying to reverse engineer
the desires and preferences of the
people that they can reach then feed red
meat to that audience but when you have
algorithms working in both directions it
completely cuts out the content creator
so I wonder I don't know within not very
long ellioto yukowski reckons that like
[__] X percent of all content on
social media is going to be created by
machines okay well I don't know are we
going to be able to compete with that I
have no idea yeah yeah it's going to get
spookier when AI is creating like
full-length like movies and songs and
stuff too
oh [__] so yeah so nothing's safe yeah
exactly so like how yeah what is that
because we again we imagine we we
appreciate things because like it was
made by a person we think that's
probably not true though right the
important thing is that we think it was
made by a person but if it wasn't like
given the fact that we presumed that the
domain of creativity and art was
something that unique to humans yeah but
actually no they can do it better so for
instance right like unobjectionably
um copywriting the the average
copywriter on the Internet is probably
not as good at copywriting as gpt4 is if
you were to say write me an advert for
this two-bedroom apartment in Austin
city center GPT for on average we'll be
able to do that better than the average
copywriter scale that all the way up
then you could the [__] I was just
thinking imagine if in five years time
you could type into whatever the new
version of chat gbt is uh create me a 10
hour extended version of Avengers end
game uh in which this thing happens
and it'll probably be able to render
that for you maybe yeah
with all of the original characters with
everybody in there
yeah it's pretty crazy and the
technology is all like it's funny
because we keep seeing the graphs of
like this is like technology it's like
this and it keeps saying like well it's
gonna slow down eventually but like you
got to figure like what 20 years ago we
didn't really even have cell phones yes
I think I was 18 when the first iPhone
came out I think it was 2007.
well remember that the the limitation at
the moment I don't think is
computational Moore's law which is that
is every three years or every
two years the number of transistors will
devil every year however many years
right that's I think that is starting to
actually top out a tiny little bit I
don't know if it is or not we're down to
like I remember I thought it was like 16
nanometers or maybe 20 nanometers was
like the theoretically smallest distance
between transistors and I think the new
tensorship or whatever coming for the
next uh Google phone is like three
nanometers uh ismozlov finally ending um
I feel like people in writing articles
like that for the past like five years
perhaps what's the status quo consensus
is that Mosler is slowing down it might
soon be augmented and then drive
improvements further right yeah [__] off
yeah that's hard to know yeah yeah okay
um and then yeah like look at this AI
stuff where it was like three two or
three years ago I don't think we cared
much it was still kind of like a meme
and now in like two years it's like [__]
game over what's happening did you ever
read super intelligence or listen to it
no so it's a book by Nick Bostrom who it
was like these seminal this is how AGI
is going to [__] us in the ass and it
came out 2014. it's kind of technical
but it's a good lesson on Audible it's
one of the books on my on my reading
list and um I remember remember saying
on this very podcast probably four years
ago I totally got red pilled by Nick
Bostrom I was adamant that this was
going to be the end of [__]
civilization and this is what's going to
happen and now I'm actually kind of
sweet with it I don't think the AGI is
that big of a threat all of the promises
that were made and all of the fears that
came out the back of it haven't happened
and in the last six months this has
completely been [__] turned on its
head yeah and it's like oh right and
this happened off basically chat Bots
and you go what a chatbot is able to do
just scale that up infinitely and that's
like [__] civilization have you seen
the movie Her
no everyone keeps on [__] telling me
to watch it uh just a guy that falls in
love with like a chatbot basically yes
but like um like here's something that I
said
um then and I still believe this is true
I think that our acceptance for new
technology I think it happens very
quickly and it's normalized very quickly
like there are some things we think
would like would never happen but as
soon as it does we'll all accept it very
fast here's one thing that I'm a little
bit worried about is I think that at
some point
chat Bots are going to get really good
at having very human-like conversations
with you and I think the idea of having
like a girlfriend chat bot I think that
once those get good enough I think
people will get very addicted to that
very quickly and it'll be like [__]
you'll have like thousands or tens of
thousands hundreds of thousand people
that have like these kind of like
Discord girlfriends that are just chat
Bots and it sounds like silly and it
sounds stupid and it sounds dumb but I
think as soon as you get one that
communicates at a good enough level with
you I think people would actually get
hooked on it human desire is a very long
lever that you can press down on
um I mean you have seen this in your
YouTube comments I haven't recently but
I did a little while ago people
unironically commenting just hold on
boys the sex robots are coming soon yeah
and that was before language learning
models and chat GPT and stuff there was
a white pill that one of my friends in
evolutionary psychologist called William
Costello told me which is you could
imagine a world in which uh VR plus
language learning models plus very
Advanced AI would create a Sandbox in
which both men and women could learn how
to interact with each other and Flow it
and it would almost be like a game so
you would practice flirting and then
that would allow you to take it because
one of the problems and one of the
reasons that people have approach
anxiety is that the cost of practicing
and the cost of failing are exactly the
same every day is game day you don't get
to go up and have practice rounds you if
you fail it's embarrassing in the real
world there's no like that's what I
always say when people are asking me
like how do you like if I want to like
practice talking to women and everything
like what do I need to do and it's like
it's super super easy you just need to
have a lot of friends that are girls and
like freshman year of high school
but if you're like 26 and you have none
you're like you're [__] this is a very
high but do you go into the gym why are
you going to the gym at 34. sure yeah a
little bit well no it's not because
going to the gym is fine I can go and
lift on my own and if you fail and snap
your [__] yeah that's but at least
that's on my own but like social
interaction is like so much but it's
like I've been friends with girls my I
had a friend group of girls because I
went to a Catholic High School that was
all boys and my friend group of girls
was at a high school it was all girls so
I was hanging with them I was getting
tons of female interaction my whole high
school life so talking to women for me
is like not a big deal but if you're
like 22 and you've never even had like a
lot of friends that are women where the
[__] you start holy [__] yes that's very
very very very very very very daunting
yeah so it's like a hard thing to
overcome yeah one of the
potential like again that was so one of
the white pills would be VR creates a
Sandbox in which people can practice
another reason why the AI girlfriend
thing is maybe not quite as seductive
for guys or girls is that there is still
no status attached to it because you're
not being chosen so there is an element
of prestige associated with being
selected and if all that you require
it's like no one brags about the fact
that they have an only fan subscription
that they're paying to like anybody with
the price of a cheeseburger spare per
month has an only fan subscription what
is special is being selected
I don't know I'm not sure I think that
that is special but there's a very real
emotional component to it as well that
might be more important yeah so maybe
the selection thing is whatever but if
the emotional thing is high enough
because like there are people that get
really I I used to think this was
[__] but um the more women I've
talked to that have done escorting the
more it seems to be true that a lot of
the people that pay for escorts really
aren't looking for like an awesome
prostitute all night they really are
just looking for like companionship
um and there's no status to buying an
escort other than I guess you have the
money to afford it but like the the
emotional companionship that you get
from it is like so big it's like [__] it
I'll pay for it you know if you're
sufficiently lonely because you're
living in this atomized pod Universal
basic income world that yeah it's hard
to think like in our world like walking
into
um I think um I [__] hate the guy but
Andrew Tate said this and it's PR I
think it's probably true that pulling up
to a party in like a [__] with the
most expensive Bugatti in the world is
not as impressive as walking into a
party with four really hot women right
yeah it's um so like but and that's
maybe people in our world might think
like that but if you're like a guy who's
like 27 years old and you've never had a
friend that's a girl before are you
really thinking is that guy at home
listening like God I just wish I had a
girl that liked me so I could show
everybody how cool I am or excuse me
like I really wish a woman would just
talk to me because I want like that
companionship you probably just wants
the emotional connection you know yeah
or even in the status signaling did you
see Tate in the new South Park no I have
not did you know that he was in it nope
Andrew Tate is represented in the new
South Park episode the one that they
finished the season with oh nice as a
Romanian sex trafficker they don't use
his name but it's the same sure haircut
it's the same glasses it's the same
beard uh and then the police come in and
again they haven't used his name but the
likeness is like so [__] So Randy
um the girls leave for spring break and
Randy is distressed at the fact that
Kyle and his friend uh Stan and his
friend are playing Warhammer 40K yeah
and this he says that this is [__]
gay like why are you doing it blah blah
blah uh I'm gonna ring someone and get
like some girls around and it's
that brings these people around it's
like I mean you've gone this season from
Harry and Megan
to Andrew studied with Harry and Megan
finished with Andrew Tay so fully all
the breadths of the internet yeah
[__] wild what else you got coming up
what can people expect from you next
um I mean tomorrow we've got all the
panel stuff going on I think I'm going
to Tennessee to debate some libertarian
guy in Ukraine Russia next month I go to
Wales and there's like yeah let's go
yeah why
um there's like a light festival or
something do you know Jack is yeah yeah
yeah he's gonna be there and a few other
people we're going to be talking about
stuff so yeah I just want a random check
on he's an interesting dude I follow a
uh an account called uh like out of
context Zizek okay and it's even in
context he's very funny he's like
[__] brilliant look Destiny I really
appreciate you man thank you for coming
out uh where should people go if they
want to check out Mario's stuff uh
instagram.com Destiny twitter.com the
Omni liberal and youtube.com Destiny
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign